So, am Start. Gerade vom Zug reingekommen und direkt Livestream an. So muss das sein.
Ich muss jetzt noch ganz schnell was essen und nebenbei muss ich mir noch ein paar Bildchen runterladen,
weil ich habe festgestellt, dass uns eindeutig noch ein paar Emotes fehlen für den Stream.
Ohne die geht es nicht.
So, machen wir mal irgendeine Playlist.
Was haben wir denn? Relaxing...
Oh, Relaxing...
Oh, nee, das ist irgendwie so ein Meditationszeug.
Ja, machen wir irgendwie sowas da. Das passt schon.
Irgendwie soll ich nicht sagen, das gedudelt.
So.
Okay, also wir brauchen unbedingt, genau, ein paar Bildchen Pornos.
Was sonst, ne?
War klar, dass das das erste sowas ist, was kommt.
So.
Dann wollen wir den Krempel erst nochmal auf Twitter posten.
Tors.
Ähm...
Twitter.
Twitter, wo ist es denn? Twitter, Twitter.
Ich bin ja mal gespannt, was Nintendo zu ihrem Online-Modus zeigt.
Omega-Lull.
Nintendo und Online ist ja immer so eine Sache, ne?
Ich verstehe...
Leute, ich verstehe auch nicht, warum Nintendo keinen ordentlichen Online-Modus hinkriegt.
Das ist mir vollkommen unbegreiflich, weil...
Ich meine...
Man muss sich ja mal überlegen.
Warte mal, ist die Lautstärke...
Ist die Lautstärke eigentlich okay?
Ja.
Wunderbar.
Das besser Test-Sound.
Wenn ihr wissen wollt, ob ihr übersteuert, müsst ihr einfach so machen.
Der Fabian kann das besonders gut.
Das habe ich vom Fabian übrigens, ja.
Weil allein komme ich auf so einen Scheiß nicht.
Ich verstehe es nicht, warum Nintendo keinen ordentlichen Online-Modus hinkriegt.
Ähm...
Ich meine...
Eigentlich...
Müsste sich Nintendo angucken...
Was macht Xbox?
Beziehungsweise macht...
Was macht Microsoft...
Seit...
Wann kam die erste Xbox raus?
Release...
Wann kam das erste Xbox Live raus?
Okay.
Also, im Prinzip müsste Nintendo einfach gucken...
Was hat Microsoft gemacht 2002?
Das war's.
Wir müssten die nicht machen, ja.
Das wäre dann schon mal...
Wenn die einfach das nehmen würden, was Microsoft 2002 gemacht hat...
Dann wären die schon mal besser...
Als ihren komischen...
Komischer Shit-Online-Modus, den sie jetzt haben.
Deswegen bin ich mal echt...
Bin ich echt gespannt, auf was Nintendo macht.
Das muss ich den Titel vom Stream hören.
Plus...
Wie heißt dieses Ding jetzt eigentlich?
Nintendo Online?
Nintendo Switch Online.
Aha.
Äh...
Hat das den...
Leute, könnt ihr mal gucken, ob das den...
Hat das den Streamtitel aktualisiert?
Nee, hat's nicht.
Was ist da los?
Warum aktualisiert das den Streamtitel nicht?
G-Baited?
Ja, Fabian, neues Smash.
Sie haben ja schon ein bisschen angeteased das Ganze.
Hat's den Titel doch aktualisiert, ja?
Ach, hat er aktualisiert.
Ja, dann.
GG Eats.
Okay, ähm...
Ich hab festgestellt, wir brauchen unbedingt noch ein paar Bildchen.
Und zwar...
Was wir überhaupt nicht haben, ist...
Ähm...
Wir brauchen einmal ein Bild für...
Mindblown.
GIF.
Den Typ brauchen wir unbedingt.
Wenn wieder irgendwas so super amazing ist, dass man das kaum aushalten kann.
Äh...
Image.fs
Das will ich binden auf...
Äh...
F4.
So, und jetzt, äh...
Ich mach gucken, ob das Ganze funktioniert, wenn ich das neu starte.
So, wie viel Zeit haben wir noch?
17 Minuten.
Ja, wunderbar.
Das passt.
Wow!
Ich hab's kaputt gemacht.
Ich hab's zerstört.
But why?
Ah, weil ich's F4 doppelt gib.
Ich bin ja auch ein Noob, ha?
Muss ich auf F5 binden.
Schreckt.
Ah, funktioniert.
Perfekt.
So, dann starten wir das andere mal neu und gucken, ob das jetzt funktioniert.
Ich hab das jetzt ja netzwerkfähig gemacht.
Bam, funktioniert.
Jawoll.
Sehr schön.
Hey, stop working, Battlefield 4.
Ja, in Battlefield 4 hatten sie das gerne.
Aber...
Macht ihr nix draus.
Mit Battlefield 5 werden die Zeiten wieder kommen, dass das am Anfang crasht.
So, ähm...
Was brauchen wir noch für ein Emote?
Wir brauchen...
Wir brauchen eigentlich noch einen großen Poggers.
Problem ist...
Leute, kennt ihr?
Ich brauch...
Ich brauch das Poggers-Emote.
Ich brauch das Poggers-Emote transparent.
Transparent und in...
Und in ordentlicher Größe.
Hat da jemand zufällig was?
Ich finde nämlich nix.
Das ist alles Mist, was ich finde.
Poggers, Alter.
Poggers.
Achso, gleich da.
Ja, äh, gleich da kann tatsächlich weg.
Das ist richtig.
Ich bin sehr brav, das stimmt.
Also, Poggers...
Poggers brauch ich noch in groß.
Und, wenn mal wieder Amerika gelobt wird, brauchen wir den hier noch.
Der ist ganz wichtig.
Kokona.
Sexbinden.
So, und dann brauchen wir noch...
Was haben wir noch?
Eine Blast RNG brauchen wir auch.
So, dann haben wir...
Für alle Situationen sind wir gewappnet.
F7.
Ich hab jetzt, ohne Scheiß, ich hab jetzt...
Glaub ich...
Acht...
Ne.
30 sogar.
WTF, nicht 18.
30, ähm...
30 Emotes.
Also, wir sind jetzt wirklich gewappnet für alle Sachen.
Okay, Funds ist alles.
Eigentlich bräuchte man noch einen Gachi-Bass oder sowas.
Was?
Song King?
Nein, Song King hab ich nicht.
Das ist das große Thinking-Emoji.
Das ist dumm.
Das ist bestimmt nicht so ein komisches Forzen-Emote oder sowas.
Was hat Nintendo eigentlich für Musik laufen?
Hören wir mal.
Nichts.
Auch gut.
Es läuft ja auch nichts bei Nintendo.
Lol, Alter.
Moin.
Tan.
Dreckso.
Ich kann den Namen leider nicht richtig lesen, weil...
Mein Better Twitch TV ist der Meinung, dass sein Name schwarz ist und ich hab das dunkle Twitch-Theme aktiviert.
Okay.
Nächster Post.
Band.
So.
Okay.
Ähm...
Hm.
Aber ich glaube, jetzt haben wir wirklich für jedes nur erdenkliche...
Sache, die in irgendeinem Stream passieren kann.
Oder in irgendwas, was wir restreamen.
Jetzt haben wir wirklich für alles irgendein Emote am Start.
Und am wichtigsten war natürlich, dass er hier noch dabei ist.
Eigentlich bräuchte man irgendwie so ein Racked-Emote oder sowas.
Was gibt's denn da Schönes?
Was hat man hier?
Racked-Gif.
Die sind alle dumm.
Den haben sie ja auch für so ziemlich alles mittlerweile schon.
Ja, ist ja blöd.
Splatoon Royale.
Die Royale-Witzerei ist nicht ab.
Nintendo Online Royale gibt's dann.
Last Man Standing Online-Modus.
Mehr schafft der Server nicht.
Das ist wahrscheinlich wirklich so.
Der Nintendo Online-Modus wird wahrscheinlich wirklich Battle Royale.
80 Millionen Leute.
Was weiß ich, wie viele wollen drauf.
So viele können es nicht sein, so viele Switches gibt's ja gar nicht.
Es wollen ein paar Millionen Leute drauf.
Gibt's nicht.
Battle Royale.
Können bloß fünf drauf.
So, machen wir das Ding mal im VLC auf.
Die haben wir aber dicht.
Katze.
Oh, ich hab einen Stern aufgetappt.
Und einen Pull-Request.
Den Pull-Request hab ich schon gesehen.
Falls dreckiger Dan am Start ist.
Ich hab mir das auch angeguckt.
Ich find's von der Idee her gut, ich bin aber überhaupt kein Fan von XNL.
Wenn Config, dann irgendwas anderes.
Und ich hab auch gestern selbst ein bisschen dran rumgebastelt.
Das heißt, ich kann das noch nicht merchen.
Ich muss mir erst mal überlegen, wie wir das...
Ähm...
Wie ich das genau machen will.
So.
Auf geht's, Nintendo.
Chasen-Config, ja wahrscheinlich.
Wahrscheinlich.
Wobei, eigentlich gar keine Config.
Wir brauchen's nicht, weil...
Also, ich hab's jetzt so gemacht.
Ihr habt's vielleicht schon...
...grad gesehen.
Ich mach einfach nen...
Äh...
...Keybinding-Unterstrich an den Namen von dem File.
Und jetzt, wenn ich jetzt mein Memeboard starte...
...bindet er mir auf Steuerung C das Image, auf Steuerung B das Image, auf Steuerung 1 das Image und sowas.
Ich finde, da braucht man gar keine Config.
Ich meine, das ist jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen trickreich, ein bisschen durch die Brust ins Auge.
Aber...
Ich find...
...darf er das mit der Config-Datei?
Noch Interesse an den Poggers?
Hab eins gefunden.
Ja, schick her.
Schick her.
Mit Keylogger, oder?
Also, ich hoffe mal mit Keylogger.
Und sonst wäre ich enttäuscht jetzt.
So.
Dann schauen wir mal, was Nintendo zu bieten an 9 Minuten.
Ne, aber um nochmal zurückzukommen auf den Online-Modus von Nintendo.
Hat ein Poggers gef...
Er hat wirklich ein Poggers gefunden.
Ähm...
Das einzige Problem bei dem Poggers ist, dass ein Copyright-Logo schräg drüber ist.
Und...
Das ist...
Ein bisschen...
Ein bisschen sehr offensichtlich, so.
Weil ich den dann irgendwo geklaut hab.
Kannst vermarkten, mein Name-Tool.
Ja.
Easy Money.
Ich meine, das ist echt geil, ne?
Wenn man sich das mal so überlegt.
Eigentlich braucht sowas jeder Streamer.
Ich hab jetzt auf dem zweiten Monitor...
Und die meisten, ne?
Die meisten haben ja heute...
Also, die das ein bisschen...
Nennen wir es mal professioneller machen.
Die haben ja alle...
Alle...
Haben sie...
Einen zweiten Rechner, über den sie streamen.
Beziehungsweise...
Einen zweiten Monitor zumindest.
Oder sowas.
Ja?
Und...
Die Kombination aus Keybindings plus auf dem zweiten Monitor quasi...
Eine Übersicht...
Mit...
Mit Bildchen.
Wenn du...
Wenn du halt drauf klickst, dann kommt das auf dem Hauptbildschirm, wo gestreamt wird.
Das ist eigentlich was, das braucht jeder Streamer.
Ich...
Es müssen ja...
Es müssen ja keine dummen...
Bildchen...
Keine dummen Meme-Bildchen sein, wie bei mir.
Ich meine, das kann ja im Endeffekt alles sein, was du da drauf einblendest.
Und sei es nur der...
Äh...
Stündliches Sell-Out.
Ich meine, das ist wirklich...
Das ist wirklich praktisch an sich, das Tool.
Fürs Streamer.
Finden wir noch nen...
Nen Mario-Facepalm.
Alter, was wird hier rumgeheult im Hintergrund?
Okay, Mario...
Das kann man echt machen.
Ähm...
Mario-Facepalm-Transparent.
Was...
Was ist denn da schön von?
Äh...
Nope.
Das...
Machen wir nicht.
Da ist gleich...
Instant-Bann von Nintendo am...
Am...
Am Start.
Ähm...
Was da?
Ich meine, das ist an sich nicht übel.
Moin.
Einsetzt...
De...
Äh...
Mario-Facepalm.
Ein Gif...
Ein was?
Ein was bitte?
Ein Gif...
C200...
Fa...
Da ist...
Da ist ein Keylogger drinne.
Ich wusste es.
Exposed.
So.
Ich brauche einen ordentlichen Mario-Facepalm.
Ich meine, wir können auch hier den Ham...
Hammer Broth...
Face...
Facepalm nehmen.
Ähm...
Was?
Wird der ein schlimmer als das andere?
Der...
Ich meine, der ist im Prinzip auch nicht schlecht dafür, ne?
Den machen wir auch nochmal rein.
F...
Wo haben wir denn jetzt?
F7 oder so, ne?
Bei Quick Bindings.
F8...
Sad Mario.
Und das Schöne ist, mein Dashboard auf dem zweiten Bildschirm zieht sich sogar die Bilder
aus...
...das Programm, ohne dass ich sie dorthin kopieren muss.
Über das Netzwerk.
Habt ihr Ubisoft schon nachgeholt?
Nein, wir haben weder Sony noch Ubisoft uns angeguckt.
Ich meine, vielleicht...
Machen wir das danach auch noch.
Irgendwie sind die Mario-Facepalms alle ganz schön...
Ganz schön doof.
Hm...
Hat der immer ein schönes Mario-Facepalm?
Das da.
Das wäre...
Das wäre nicht schön.
Was ist denn...
Was ist denn das noch?
Das ist doch auch streetspeichert.
Ich glaube sowas ist echt schlecht.
Beide sind...
Das sind...
Das...
Ich guck nochmal transparent.
Muss doch auch ein transparent geben.
Ich speichere den Krempel jetzt als..
Das war so...
Nehm das auf das Bild mit Maria und Luigi, ne, ne.
Also wenn ihr wollt.
Und mal gucken wie lange Nintendo geht, aber die sind ja meistens relativ, relativ zackig.
Können wir uns danach noch ein bisschen die Highlights angucken von Sony und von Ubisoft.
Ich habe gehört das Frodo auf der Bühne war bei Ubisoft.
Okay.
und irgendein verwirrendes Game
vorgestellt hat.
Komm, ich steh mal jetzt das hier.
Okay, neu laden.
Zack.
Das funktioniert echt gut, muss ich sagen.
Da hab ich schon was ordentliches, Poker.
Ja, Pfunst.
Nein, das sieht scheiße aus, aber ich mein
besser als nix.
Programming Skills.
Bist du dieses Jahr auf der Gamescom? Wahrscheinlich nicht.
Gamescom ist
total sinnlos.
Ich hab mir jetzt ja mal
zwei Jahre die volle Ladung
gegeben, also mit fast einer Woche da.
Plus den ganzen Tag irgendwelche Termine.
Plus den ganzen Tag sinnlos Gelaber.
Da kommt so wenig bei rum.
Und letztendlich fährst du fast besser.
Du guckst jetzt von daheim aus an
in Ruhe. Das ist leider so.
Gamescom kann man machen,
wenn man das noch nie gemacht hat, aber an sich, ich weiß nicht.
Eigentlich, da kommt auch
so wenig bei rum, letztendlich.
So, machen wir mal aus.
Ah, komm.
Dauert noch zwei Minuten.
Schauen wir mal. Ich wollte eigentlich was essen.
Wärmt mir grad so ein.
Lull. Mega Lull.
Ja, ein Tag. Aber für
einen Tag lohnt sich's wiederum nicht,
sich alles mögliche zu besorgen.
Weißt du, wenn ich den
schon einen Ausweis aus den
Rippen leiern muss für zwei Personen,
da stellen sie sich nämlich immer
extrem an.
Oh, wir haben einen Pogger.
Poggers. Nice.
Poggers.
Den hauen wir jetzt noch ganz schnell rein.
Poggers. Ach komm, den hauen wir das nächste Mal rein.
Wir haben jetzt schon den Mario dabei.
Äh.
Poggers. Poggers.
Alter, Poggers.
Ach komm, wir können auch neu starten.
Schnell.
Famous last words.
Geht schnell. Bam, bam.
Hast du jetzt, hast du jetzt das, ähm,
das Copyright raus
aus Photoshop oder was?
Könntest du mir richtig vorstellen, ne?
So, Max, Max beschwert sich ja
auf dem Bild, ist ein Copyright,
ist ein Copyright-Schriftzug drauf.
Was macht er? Ja, komm, einfach Copyright-Schriftzug
raus Photoshoppen.
Poggers. Poggers.
Poggers Photoshop-Skills.
Oh, wow.
Was geht los?
Dieser Switch-Sound immer. Zu leise.
Zu leise, Nintendo.
Okay.
Wenn 100%
nicht genug ist.
Immer noch zu leise, oder?
Nintendo, was macht ihr denn?
Jetzt, so ist gut, oder?
Ist das Nintendo, was wir hier gucken?
Was, was, was sehe ich da gerade?
Ist das Nintendo?
Ja.
Ja, das ist wirklich Nintendo.
Was zum Teufel war das?
Alle Weeps am Start.
Oh, jetzt schreien sie aber.
Muss ich leiser machen?
Die Dinger sind unterschiedlich laut
abgemischt, irgendwie.
Das ist ja zügigst laut.
Irgendwelche JRPG-Geschichten.
Das heißt, das sind nicht so, wie es aussieht.
Das war schon auch so ein bisschen
viele Tage gleich,
die es eben Brilliant Games
nicht mehr gemacht haben.
Ich wusste noch nicht,
dass das so etwas gewesen wäre.
Und damit history und
sie wird es so oft.
Ich weiß nicht,
ob das auf die Hauptwelt
auch mehr
gibt.
Ich weiß gar nicht,
ob ich mir das da
wirklich richtig
in den Augen
bewegen sollte.
Oh, ne?
Ich weiß nicht.
Es wird einfach
schlechter.
Ich finde es
ist doch
mycket
schwerer als
Nintendo.
Aber ich muss
auch noch weiter
schauen,
Keine Ahnung, da müsste ich den Master-Grubber mal fragen.
This game is fun.
A few weeks ago, we showed you Pokémon Let's Go Pikachu and Pokémon Let's Go Eevee.
A brand new Pokémon adventure through the vibrant Kanto region,
where your partner, Pikachu or Eevee, is always by your side.
Add the transformative power of Nintendo Switch,
and you can play as you like, anywhere you like,
or for the first time in this series,
catch or battle Pokémon on one system with a friend.
You can even transfer a Pokémon into the game from Pokémon Go.
This is a Pokéball Plus.
You can use it like a Joy-Con controller with Pokémon Let's Go Pikachu and Let's Go Eevee,
or play the entire game with it alone.
You can put a Pokémon into the Pokéball Plus,
and then bring it with you.
It sounds like there's already one inside.
It's the mythical Pokémon Mew.
Mew comes exclusive with every Pokéball Plus
and can join you on your journey through the game.
Pokémon Let's Go Pikachu,
Pokémon Let's Go Eevee,
and the Pokéball Plus will be available on November 16th.
Discover new friends and challenges
as you explore this mysterious and enchanting world.
Wherever you go, with whoever you like,
only on Nintendo Switch.
Now, let's check out something else we can't wait to show you.
Das macht, das macht Bunny bei Nintendo.
Oh nein, es wird cringe.
RL-Videos werden immer...
The fuck?
Hey, what's up?
What are y'all doing?
I'm playing.
Genau, so läuft es in echt auch immer, wenn du irgendwo rumstehst.
We need to have...
Oh, game on.
Mario Party Royale.
Are you guys ready to do this?
Fasten inside.
Alright, ready?
Yeah.
Juhu!
One more.
We should do one more.
Rematch.
Also wenn die...
Wenn das offline ist,
weil der Fabian schreibt,
das ist ja auch gerade.
Also wenn das wirklich wieder nur offline ist
oder halt irgendwas, was nicht da auch geschreit,
dann weiß ich auch nicht.
Ich mein, ja okay, es ist ja gut,
dass man es fördern will,
dass die Leute offline spielen können
und wenn sie sich offline befreien,
sich offline treffen und es spielen,
sagt ja keiner was gegen.
Aber heutzutage
wollen auch die Leute online spielen.
Auch wenn das Nintendo nicht wahrhaben will.
Ist das jetzt Fire Emblem oder irgendwie sowas?
Irgendwie sowas in der Richtung.
Oder auch nicht.
Oder doch.
Oder nicht.
Fire Emblem, sag ich doch.
Edelgard.
So heißen Leute auch nur in japanischen RPGs.
Die Japaner sind geil.
Wenn sie so fake deutsche Namen immer nehmen.
Ich wollte auch schon immer mal
in der Armee sein, angeführt von Edelgard.
Wieso wegfliegen?
Oh, noch mal gestöhnt am Ende.
Aber das musste wohl sein.
Viva Piniata.
Nein.
Fortnite.
Nein, nicht Fortnite.
Das sieht aber sehr ähnlich.
Oder was ist das?
Ist das doch Fortnite?
Es ist auf jeden Fall...
Ja, es ist Fortnite.
Endlich.
Endlich, da habe ich drauf gewartet.
Ja, genau.
Weil du das bestimmt auch spielst.
Nintendo Switch.
Das ist eine Home-Console, wo du eine volle Menge an
Game-Inso양en einbezogen haben kannst,
das bedeutet eine Menge von ground-breaking Games
aus unserer individuellen Entwicklungs-Community.
Genau Fabian, danke mir.
Das Spiel-Games auf Nintendo Switch hat inspirierend.
Und alles von euch,
dass alle Entwickler, die sich hinter diesen
reichen, verwirrenden Erfahrungen abissant sind,
von allen von uns hier bei Nintendo,
danke euch dafür.
Wir müssen die Tür zurückdrehen auf ein paar mehr.
Zuletzt die zwei, die wir zum ersten Mal zeigen.
Hallo, Fabia.
Aspiring Chefs,
ready your cleavers, pots and cutting boards
in Overcooked 2.
A sequel that's brand new with more recipes,
characters, kitchens
and white-knuckle-makes.
Prepare for the ultimate cook-off
with new features like the ability
to throw ingredients,
kitchens that can change on the fly
and with Nintendo Switch
the opportunity to bake,
barbecue or broil with another player
in wireless, local
and online play.
Save the world from clumsy cooking
and teams of the team
to claim food jobs
and thrive on the spot.
Hop on a snail,
board-bearing,
fight off the enemy's queen
to claim victory
in Killer Queen Black.
Redesign from the ground up
Liquid Bit and Bumble Bear Games
acclaimed arcade extravaganza
that became a multiplayer phenomenon
is coming to Nintendo Switch.
And for the first time on console
two teams of up to
four million people
can square off an exciting battle.
Play first on Nintendo Switch
later this year.
Killer Queen Black.
Okay, LOL4D, hier.
LOL4D, nur für euch.
Super Spinning LOL4D HD Edition.
Das ist aber gut.
Das Game ist gut.
Also, das LOL4D passt dazu gar nicht.
Das Hollow Knight ist nice.
That offers endless hours
of intricate exploration.
We revealed earlier this year
that Hollow Knight was coming
to Nintendo Switch.
And I'm pleased to announce
that the game,
packed with all the previous
downloadable content,
is available on the Nintendo eShop
starting today.
These are just a few
of the terrific indie games
to play in the months ahead.
After this presentation,
stay tuned for Nintendo Treehouse Live,
streaming right from the E3 show floor,
where our Nintendo game experts
will give you a closer look at the game.
to a closer look at some of these games and more.
Ne, das gucken wir uns nicht mal an.
And I personally cannot wait to watch
as intrepid challengers test their mettle
in our Splatoon World Championships
and Super Smash Bros. invitational
Splatoon eSports.
The action starts immediately following
Nintendo Treehouse Live.
Splatoon eSports, LOL.
I have an important update on a game
I know fans have been looking forward to.
Octopath Traveler from Square Enix
is coming soon.
I don't know how the game will be played,
but I like the way it looks.
And you can download a brand new demo
for the game from the Nintendo eShop
on June 14th.
Now, let's take another
action-packed look at some more
experiences coming soon
to Nintendo Switch.
.
als remaster warum nicht? Monster Hunter, okay. Das ist bestimmt für einige geil. Wolfenstein 2,
doch jetzt nach einem Jahr kommt es auch auf der Switch raus. Mario und Tennis.
Every time I see that, I can't help but smile. At Nintendo, we approach development with the goal
of delivering new and unique games to surprise people all over the world, and we're thankful
for the many publishing partners also making games for Nintendo Switch. Today we share just
a small portion of what we're currently working on. We hope you will look forward to what's coming
next on Nintendo Switch. Now, it's time to share information on a certain title. I'll turn it over
to you.
Oh, jetzt geht der Fabian ab.
So, we made a video to showcase some fighters appearing in the game. The number next to each fighter signifies the order in which they joined the Super Smash Bros. series. Please, take a look.
Klingt mir nach einem Balancing-Albtraum, so viele Helden zu haben.
Also so als Außenstehender, ich habe wie gesagt von der Serie keine Ahnung.
Klingt aber nach nicht zu balancen mit irgendwie wachweilig wie vielen Helden drinnen.
Jetzt schauen wir uns die anderen Kämpfe an, die sich verändert haben.
Wir sehen uns in der letzten Ausgabe.
Mario ist immer noch leicht zu verwenden, aber wir haben noch etwas oder jemanden von seiner neuesten Abenteuer.
Er kann auch seine Gebärmutter- und Bauern-Outfits tragen.
Link träumt von seiner Champions-Tunik aus der Legende von Zelda Breath of the Wild.
Seine Bomben sind jetzt remote detoniert und sein letzter Schuss erlischt die Zipfel.
Er kann auch Links fremde Tunik aus der Wilde tragen.
Auch während der Anzeige von Nazis ist er immer noch bleibend beim An QR- gehst.
Er steht nur noch für einen Moment tiefer mit den passenden Elementen in seiner Küche
auch hatte er die Geister zwar zu ernst oder nur seit 800 Jahren den indoorer Fest uhled,
aber nach dem Ent reinst apausierender Tier gab seine東西 nachsehbar
Einer auffälliger Start im Duell ist wieder mal auf Krieg?
Wo
hängt sich über Steam?
Einer ist gar nicht erfasst.
Das ist es.
theat, Meeting 2,ara bugün benachrichtigt für heute.
Wir haben nun die weibliche Version von Pikachu, vollständig mit einem kräftigen Haar.
Habt ihr bemerkt, dass Pikachu Libre eine Frau ist?
Foxes Design ist nun auf Star Fox Zero basiert und seine Final Smash hat einen Überfall erhalten.
Diesmal sind die Final Smashes direkt am Punkt, damit ihr sofort zurück in die Kämpfe kommen könnt.
Valkos Final Smash bietet eine unorthodoxe Schiffsformation, die mehr unruhig ist als Foxes.
Egal wie, der Landmeister ist verabschiedet.
In Ein-zu-ein-Fighten wird Ryu immer seinen Opponenten treffen, so wie in seinen originalen Spielen.
Es ist ein kleiner Schuss, der unnötige Anzeichen reduziert.
Anzeichen, wie Samus' Anzeichen-Schuss, können nun im Mittelfeld erzeugt werden.
Er ist schneller und es ist einfacher, einen nach dem anderen zu entlasten.
Dies hält für Roy und Lucina auch für wahr.
Außerdem ist Marth jetzt vollständig im Englischen.
Bleibt eure Augen offen!
Zurück bei Popular Demand.
Veteranen-Fighter Snake fliegt zurück in den Fray.
Es ist schon seit 10 Jahren, seit seiner letzten Appearance in der Serie.
So können wir endlich neue Wettbewerbe durchführen.
Natürlich ist auch Shadow Moses Island zurück.
King Dedede's Final Smash ist im Grunde ein Käse-Fight, in dem er Missile und einen Jet-Hammer erzeugt.
Pichu wird auch von Super Smash Bros. Melee zurück.
Sein elektrisches Schock verursacht sich auch immer noch.
Also seid vorsichtig!
In The Legend of Zelda Chapter 1 ist Zelda mehr in der Forschung als im Kampf.
Aber ihr Design ist von The Legend of Zelda in between worlds.
Zelda ist viel eleganter und regaler als unsere anderen Krieger.
Das ist die Link between worlds Style, okay?
Ich kann's sagen, weil die sieht komplett anders aus.
Her final smash is a ceiling move called Triforce of Wisdom.
Sonics final smash, Super Sonic, is more souped up than ever.
Either you're too slow, or he's lightning fast.
Pac-Man also got a speed boost this time around.
Looping her on the stage sounds just like Pac-Man, don't you think?
Pokémon Trainer is back.
With Squirtle, Ivysaur and Charizard.
You can change Pokémon during battle.
And this time there's no penalty for sticking with one.
So feel free to pick your main.
Also, you can play as a female trainer for the first time.
Some fighters, like Captain Falcon, trigger a dramatic slow-mo effect on strong attacks in one-on-one fights.
And of course, his hazardous big blue stage is making a return.
You can play as a female trainer in a final fantasy 7-costume or his final fantasy 7-advent-children-costume.
Just like before, you can play as a female trainer in his final fantasy 7-costume or his final fantasy 7-advent-children-costume.
Now you can see his limit gauge near his damage percentage at all times.
Special displays are available for certain other fighters too.
For example, you can see how much longer Robin can use Leaven Sword and Tomes.
Who the hell is Robin?
For Villager, we made it easier to see what you've pocketed.
Between the male and female versions, there are eight different Villagers.
Bowser's final smash, Giga Bowser, is even bigger and better.
He's now as big as Bowser from the Yoshi's Island game.
All of Mr. Game & Watch's moves are back, and he looks even more like he did in his original games.
His transformations are more complex than ever.
Young Link from Super Smash Bros. Melee is making a comeback that makes three Links for the first time.
What for?
His design is based on Star Fox Zero, and each of his moves seem to be a significant upgrade.
Kirby is his usual puffy self.
But we've added a little something to his stone ability.
He has a copy ability for every fighter, so the more fighters we have, the more challenging he becomes to develop.
Shulk used to require repeated button presses to toggle Monado Arts.
But now you can choose a specific one with a button press and a quick directional tilt.
Sure is handy for his final smash.
We also added Fiora to his final smash.
Ganondorf rises again, returning to his popular design from The Legend of Zelda Ocarina of Time.
And for his final smash, he becomes Demon King Ganon.
Me-Fighters proportions have been tweaked a bit.
There are three types. Brawler, Swordfighter and Gunner.
The moveset for each type has also been enhanced, and you can now choose from 12 voice options.
We're hoping to get this fighter ready for online play.
Okay, ich glaub die zeigen echt alle.
Dann haben sie sonst nicht viel zu zeigen.
In the last game, Zero Suit Samus' final smash called in her gunship.
This time, she uses her horse to fire a devastating laser.
When Olimar gets damaged, you'll see a crack in his helmet.
But don't worry, it'll get fixed up right away.
Bayonettas costumes from her first two games are both available.
Listen closely, and you'll hear differences in the sound of them.
It seems we have a guest.
Rodan appears as an assist trophy.
Warrior's final smash, Warrior Man, has changed quite a bit.
After transforming, he no longer uses individual attacks to get the job done.
Donkey Kong's final smash is all rapid fire punches, like Donkey Kong Jungle Beater.
You'll notice that he and other fighters have expressive new facial animations.
Little Man's final smash is now a bunch of blows from Giga Man.
In fact, all final smash moves in the game get right to the punch.
Ness' new final smash calls on Kala and Pooh.
Of course, Jeff still shows up as an assist trophy.
Likewise, Lucas' final smash features Kimatora and Boney.
At first glance, we fit trainers seeing him as an assist trophy.
But her face has a new look.
I wavered a bit on whether to change it, but it was a request from the Wii Fit developers.
We've included all the hazards from both versions of Mega Man's stage from Super Smash Bros. for Wii U and Nintendo 3DS.
And for his final smash, say hello to Proto Man and Bass.
Palutena's special attacks have been streamlined this time around, and her down special is
now both a counter and a deflector.
Rob has a new gauge on his chassis, showing how much fuel he has left for hovering.
Das ist echt richtig cool, Story Bob!
Wahrscheinlich werde ich gleich von den Smash-Fernzügels geflamed.
Magst du Cagnouf get good at Smash?
Oder irgendwie sowas.
Let me introduce you to a brand new Echo Fighter.
Daisy joins the roster as Peach's Echo Fighter.
She fights in a similar manner as Peach, but they have different characteristics, which
we hope you'll enjoy.
Have fun playing as your favorite Princess Peach.
All in all, if you add up the changes we're making, there could be tens of thousands.
I hope you're looking forward to some serious matchups.
Ich hab ja schon mal gesagt, dass Rosalina mein Lieblingscharakter aus der ganzen Mario-Serie
ist.
Ich weiß auch nicht so genau warum, aber wenn's an mir geht, darf Rosalina in jedem
Game vorkommen.
If you ink opponents, they'll take more damage from attacks.
Different weapons are available as Smash-Attacks or Special-Attacks.
The Splattershot, Splat-Bomb, Splat-Roller, and the final Smash, Killer Whale.
Die müssen doch was zu Nintendo Online zeigen.
Unbedingt.
Und sei es auch, dass man drüber lachen kann.
Ich will das sehen.
Bitte yang, bitte.
Btw.
Wir haben die Squid-Sisters als quelques Tr推 ein
damages.
Durch ihr concert-Soonserald wir supports an der Kamera ziehen.
Das bedeutet, dass es besser nur so nach darauf possibile, dass Ende zurecht.
Was war das denn gerade? Was hat der hinter dem gemacht?
Ha? Was war das?
Rund.
Zum Beispiel Sims.
Das kann man doch nie und immer balancen. Wie soll das funktionieren?
Wie viele Helden gibt es jetzt? 980?
Oh, da war ein Scheiß komplett aufbalancen. Könnte natürlich auch sein.
Okay.
New Pog City.
Aber die Musik ist geil.
All Stages now have both Battlefield and Omega Forms 2.
These versions hover above an abyss.
Ich bin mal gespannt, ob sie sagen, ob das Spiel Surfer hat oder ob es P2P ist oder sowas.
Weil das muss ja beim letzten Teil nicht gut gelaufen sein.
Let's take a sneak peek at the new and returning techniques you can pull off during battles.
The directional air dodge enhances mobility.
It can come in handy when...
...you're recovering from a fall.
However, if you dodge too much, even on the ground, you'll be wide open to attack and your duration of intangibility gets shorter.
You can execute short hop attacks by pressing the A button and jump at any time.
Die sind wirklich ausführlich, muss man sagen, ja.
Also, you can smash attack by pressing the A and B buttons, just like the previous game.
A perfect shield occurs when you release the shield button.
Until now, you were able to pull it off without any damage.
Without any major risks, but going forward, you'll need to time it carefully.
Fabian, wenn Rosalina OP ist
in dem neuen Game, spiele ich auch
Das war Informations-Overload, ey
Oh, ist doch nicht fertig
Oh, Classic-Controller
Poggers
Na endlich
Ich hoffe, das geht auch für andere Games
Hoffentlich mein gescheiter Controller
für die Search
Hoffentlich geht das für andere Games auch
Bitte schauen Sie sich das mal an
Das ist die beste Idee, muss man sagen
Also man ist in einem Anzug, ja
und möchte gegen irgendwie den Boss fighten
macht es dann aber nicht, sondern steigt aus dem Anzug
aus, um dann ohne Anzug gegen den Boss
zu fighten
So macht man's
So ist es
Bestimmt nicht schon früher, wenn ich da drauf gekommen bin
Wie, was ist jetzt?
Was ist?
Alter, wie sieht's
Was ist mit Nintendo Online-Modus?
Los Angeles, E3-Kaijo
Nintendo Treehouse Live
The fuck?
Sonst nix?
Wie?
Hä?
Warum? Nintendo, warum?
Komm, Leute
Moment, ich muss jetzt mal nachgucken
Gibt's denn, gibt's denn
Nintendo, gibt's dazu neue Online?
Gab's dazu
im Vorfeld schon irgendwas Neues
oder so?
Sieht nicht so aus
Das
Das war ja lame, ey
Hm
Tja
Da fällt mir jetzt auch nix mehr ein, zu gerade
Ähm, tja
Na gucken wir mal, ne
Wann launchen das eigentlich
nochmal, genau
September, September 2018
Genau
Tja, ähm, gut
Da sind wir, im Prinzip sind wir jetzt durch
Leider vorbei
alles
Ähm, ich glaub Nintendo
waren die Letzten
Im Bunde
Bop
Was war das?
Okay, also, was haben wir denn gestern verpasst?
Ich, ich will mir nochmal
Jetzt, ich muss mir zumindest mal angucken, was bei Ubisoft war
Und was, und dann gucken wir mal
So, einfach nochmal die Trailer
Wollen wir uns nochmal
Ah, ich weiß nicht, wie viele Leute das von euch geguckt haben
Ähm
Wollen wir nochmal schnell uns die Trailer anschauen
Von Ubisoft und von Sony
Weil ich hab noch nix gesehen
Okay, Beyond Good & Evil 2 interessiert mich nicht
Transference, das ist da wo Frodo auf der Bühne war, das interessiert mich auch nicht
Skull & Bones könnten wir uns angucken
Wobei mich das ehrlich gesagt auch nicht interessiert
Das ist so ein, das ist wahrscheinlich, das ist quasi Sea of Thieves in, in hoffentlich gut
Aber juckt, juckt mich auch nicht
Nee, das ist Resident Sleeper, das juckt nicht
Das neue Assassin's Creed gucken wir uns jetzt an, da hab ich noch nichts dazu gesehen
Das müssen wir uns noch angucken
Dann bin ich mal gespannt
Das ist auch ein Setting, dem ich echt was
Gamestar Editor, was ist denn das?
Guckt mal
Ne, ich mach Pause
Und was erwartet man von nem gescheiten Video Editor?
Man erwartet, wenn ich von Play auf Pause wechsle
Und danach die Zeit ändere, dass er dann weiter auf Pause bleibt
Aber nicht so der Gamestar Video Editor
So
Jetzt, wir müssen uns nochmal kurz Assassin's Creed angucken
Hab ich noch nichts von gesehen
Aber Griechenland ist ein Setting, das könnte mir gut gefallen
Moment, stopp
Ich, nein, ich kann mir das nicht auf Deutsch angucken, das geht nicht
Das ist leider nicht möglich
Ähm, E3 Trailer Assassin's Creed 2018
Ja, besser
Ist halt Origins in Griechenland
Naja, Assassin's Creed ist immer Assassin's Creed, bloß in
Das war schon immer so
Assassin's Creed, hahaha
Wie soll ein Kind uns retten?
Moment, warum ist das auch auf Deutsch?
Ich will nicht wissen, wie ein Kind uns retten kann
Ich will das auf Englisch erstmal haben
Das kann ja zu schwierig sein
Oh, NA, sehr gut, das kommt jetzt
Ah, die jebaiten mich aber hier des Todes gerade
Oh
Jetzt aber
Word Reveal
How can a child save us all?
Okay, ist auch nicht besser
Tell me, Nikolaus
Warum reden die Griechen eigentlich Englisch?
Lol, das war schlecht
Where we begin, before you, I see a path
Built by friendship and family
Love and loss, war and bloodshed
Ich mein, das macht was her, ah, muss man schon sagen
You were sent by the gods to protect this world
Also mir gefällt die Epoche auch echt gut
Aminas, as you write your Odyssey across the mountains and the seas
Remember, the fate of Greece journeys with you
Hab ich euch schon mal gesagt, dass man sowohl mit Schwertern als auch mit Speeren nicht springt beim Angreifen?
Nur mal so
Das machen sie immer gerne, macht man aber nicht
Warum sollte man das machen?
Wie, das war's? Mehr Infos gibt's nicht?
Gameplay Demo, das gucken wir uns mal an, das interessiert mich wirklich
Also ich, die Epoche finde ich super
Also da bin ich wirklich mal gespannt
Was geht denn da?
Ist das Ellie?
Oh, Ellie Kappa Pride
Das müssen wir uns danach auch noch angucken
Ich muss, wir müssen uns jetzt noch das Assassin's Creed Gameplay anschauen
Hi, I'm Scott Phillips, Game Director on Assassin's Creed Odyssey
Hi, Scott
Today I'm excited to give you a sneak peek
A sneak peek at three years of hard work from the Ubisoft Quebec team
And our transformation into a full blown RPG with choice at the center of everything
In Assassin's Creed Odyssey you will play a mercenary who embarks on an epic Odyssey
Leute, Leute, wenn wir fertig sind, wollen wir uns nochmal den Smash Trailer angucken?
Epic Odyssey to reunite their family and confront the ones who tore it apart
Your ship, the Adrestia, will be your home base and its crew like family
As you seek adventure sailing the Aegean Seas and exploring the lands of 5th century BC ancient Greece
And for the first time ever you will choose to play as either a male or female hero
Moment, gab's das nicht in London auch schon?
Hat man, ich hab das nicht gespielt
Jetzt ne Frage an euch für die, die das Assassin's Creed London Ding gespielt haben
Ich hab schon wieder vergessen wie es heißt
Wie hieß denn das? Assassin's Creed, keine Ahnung, das in London
Ähm, hat man da nicht auch ein Mädel gespielt?
Cassandra, both heroes will share the same story and gameplay
Ja, gut, ich mein, warum nicht?
Heutzutage
Possibilities
So, so
Today we're going to play
Wobei, Moment, jetzt mal, ich will nicht flamen, Leute
Ich will auch nicht mit der, ich will auch nicht mit der Emotionsdebatte anfangen
Ähm, wie es bei Battlefield der Fall ist, ja
Ich will, ich will, ich will, aber eins muss ich sagen
Das war noch spartaner, oder?
Ist es, gab es, gibt es eine Historie, jetzt mal so an die, an die, an die, an die Historie?
Historie-Pros, ja?
Gibt es Aufzeichnungen von weiblichen spartaner Soldatinnen?
Zumindest hat sie keine Armprothese
Ist ja schon mal was
Oh ne, Band, Exposed, alles, Anzeige ist raus
Both heroes will share the same story and gameplay possibilities
Today we're going to play as Cassandra as she arrives at the beautiful Greek island of Mykonos
Mykonos represents just one of eight different biomes of ancient Greece
Each with their own style, stories and adventures
We will discover
In Assassin's Creed Odyssey
Die Quali ist, die Quali ist freudig
Was ist das hier?
This is key
Rapid retrospect games
Könnte ich mal ordentlich streamrappen, oder was?
And that's why we've introduced interactive dialogues
Ah, Mykonos Island
Built from the corpses of giants
Slain by the legendary Herakles
Read me the note again
Eagle-bearing Mystios
That's you
We are a small but fierce group of rebels
Who pay you handsomely to help us overthrow our Athenian oppressors
What did your informant tell you?
Their adventures
There's also word of Spartans landing on Mykonos
So, I'm here to find a peer who wants me to kill the
Hahaha
Mercenaries are powerful enemies hired to hunt you down
Odyssey takes place during the Peloponnesian War
A time when the two powerhouses of Sparta and Athens are fighting for control of all Greece
Spartans and Athenians both use mercenaries to do their dirty work
Ja, aber die Athen haben glaube ich übelst auf die Fresse gekrischt
But they also have armies of their own
Wenn ich mich da richtig dran erinnern kann
War das nicht so?
Jetzt mal Geschichtsunterricht auspacken
War das nicht so, dass die, dass die Athener, dass da die halbe Armee ins Meer gefallen ist bei Nacht?
Ha? Da war doch was
Das kann nicht gut sein
Wir sind mit einem anderen Mercenarier übernommen, der Kassandra fährt
Geschichte in 2K18 lol
Durch das Tötchen von Mercenariern wie Malleus
Kannst du letztendlich der berühmte und furchtbare Mercenarier der alten Grieche werden
Nur eine der vielen Side-Story von Assassin's Creed Odyssey
Du willst meinen Kopf?
Komm und nimm ihn!
Der Kampf in Assassin's Creed Odyssey fokussiert sich auf Offensivität und schnelles Bewegung
Statt auf Block
Ich kann mich da, das hab ich mal irgendwo gelesen, dass dann die Athener gegen, frag mich nicht
Die Griechen haben sich ja damals alle die Köpfe eingeschlagen untereinander
Und die Athener haben irgendwie gelagert bei Nacht, also Lager aufgeschlagen
Und bevor sie angreifen wollten am nächsten Tag
Haben sie noch auf ihre Verbündeten gewartet
Und die Verbündeten von den Athenern, die hatten allerdings einen ähnlichen Dialekt
Ich weiß, Residenz Lipa und so
Die hatten einen ähnlichen Dialekt wie die Spartaner
Und die Verbündeten sind dann quasi Richtung das Lager nachts von den Athenern gelaufen
Und haben gesungen, so Kriegsgesang-mäßig
Und die Athener haben übelst Schiss gekriegt, weil sie gedacht haben, die Spartaner greifen sie an
Und dann wollten sie fliehen und das Lager war halt an Klippen zum Meer
Und dann ist irgendwie die halbe Armee ins Meer gefallen
Griechische Geschichte bei Max, los!
Okay, es sieht aus wie Assassin's Creed
Oh!
Noch mehr RPG-Elemente
Ich weiß nicht, ob das unbedingt sein muss
Und ein Skill bauen
Na gut
Das muss eigentlich nicht sein, das wirkt schon ein bisschen aufgesetzt irgendwie
Loot-Crime
Da ist er dabei
Ein Multiplayer beim Casten dann, Fabian
Dann ist nix mit Loot-Crime
Das wird weggecrapped
Man kann Zeugs auswählen in den Dialogen
Kasandra hat beschlossen, den Rebellen in einer Konkurs-Battel zu helfen
Diese Konkurs-Battel bieten hunderten Soldaten gegen einander an
Und können mit oder ohne die Hilfe der Spieler stattfinden, wenn eine Nation schwach wird
Das Ergebnis dieser Battel, wie auch eure Wahl im Spiel, wird dramatische Auswirkungen haben
Und die Zukunft von Griechenland darstellen
Das erinnert mich, wisst ihr, das erinnert mich voll an, an, an Dings hier
Es ist Sons of Rome, oder wie hieß das?
Rise?
Dieses, das sah auch so ähnlich aus, das hat auch nach jedem Hit kurz, kurz geleckt
Das, dieses Crytek, Crytek Xbox-Release-Game
Ah, Juggernauts gab's auch schon in der Antike
Also wenn ich mal so den, den, ich weiß, Realismus-Vergleich
Wenn ich mal so ankomme, so von den Verhältnissen her
Ähm, der, der würde die normalerweise einfach instant rippen, ja, also instant, instant gip, instant...
Down, ja
Und außerdem, man springt beim Angreifen nicht
Hat denn das doch keiner erzählt, oder was?
Combat in Odyssey is fueled by adrenaline
Adrenaline is earned by dodging, parrying, and landing hits on enemies
When the player has enough adrenaline, it can be unleashed
Haha, Sirius Max, genau
Pik-Shark
Wow
Enrage
But your enemies have abilities of their own
And will challenge you like never before
With Diakles dead, Mykonos Island will now be controlled by the Spartans
Na gut
Thank you for watching, I hope you've enjoyed the...
Okay
Naja, naja, ja...
Also das Setting, da kann man richtig was geiles draus machen
Aus dem Assassin's Creed in Griechenland, das hat mich eh gewundert, dass das nicht schon viel früher gekommen ist, ja
Ähm, also aus dem Setting kann man richtig viel machen
Mal gucken, was da rauskommt
So, jetzt gucken wir uns noch Last of Us 2 an
Da gucken wir mal, was es sonst noch so gab
Danach gucken wir uns nochmal Super Smash Bros. an, weil ich hab mir nicht alles merken können
Bisschen leise, hä?
Soll ich mal auf die Wand gehen, wenn du eine deiner Pläne rauskommst?
Ja
Sie ist äh...
Aber nicht ganz so gut
Easy Clap
Da gibt es zwei Wochen, bis wir zusammenbleiben
Das wird nicht passieren
Sie äh...
Sagt etwas zu dir?
Ich werde es in einer Woche machen
Ellie!
Hey!
Was hat dich so lange gedauert?
Irgendwas stimmt mit dem Sound nicht
Jesse
Vergesst nicht, dass wir das erste Licht verlassen müssen, um etwas zu retten
Ja klar, Sibaro, höre ich das
Ja, Sir
Was... War das...
Komm schon
War das live auch so, oder haben die das einfach schlecht gerippt hier, die, die, die...
Oh, müssen wir uns einen anderen Trailer suchen, oder war das in echt auch so?
Nein, war nicht so, okay
Dann suchen wir uns...
War live auch so?
Ja, was jetzt?
Was nun?
Okay, das war in echt auch so, also live war das auch so, okay
Können wir auch hier weitergucken
Direkt daneben in der Playstation Trailer
Was?
Ah!
Ja, dann nehmen wir doch das
Da!
Diese Sche...
Alter!
Leckt mich, äh...
Okay, wir haben jetzt ein bisschen verpasst, wie Ellie, äh, gedanzt hat, aber das ist okay
Okay, Gameplay geht ein paar...
Minuten...
Minute los
Danach müssen wir Death Stranding gucken, da bin ich auch gespannt drauf
Ich, ich predikte jetzt mal was
Für das Game
Ich weiß nicht, wann es rauskommt, ich predikte mal was
Die Linke überlebt es nicht
Na, was für Wörter hier
Das hat es bei Nintendo nicht gegeben
Instant Bann
Erinnert mich ein bisschen an Tomb Raider
Sorry, Tomb Raider
So, Grill mit Bogen auf dem Rücken
Und an, an...
Gegner anstelzen
Ja, Yoshi, gäbe ich dir recht, die Animationen sind gut
Aber das könnt, das kann Naughty Dog
Animationen haben die wirklich absolut geile Sachen
Uncharted war, war Vorreiter
Das erste Uncharted in, in, in guten Animationen
Die haben die anderen ewig gebraucht, bis sie das hingekriegt haben
Und kriegen sie aber noch nicht hin
Animationen können sie
Wo ist der Sinn davon, ihn zu erstechen?
Sie wollten ihn gerade erhängen
Äh
Bäh
Doppelt hält besser
Ja, manchmal weiß man nicht so genau
Für die Dramatik war das wichtig
Eddie erlegt jetzt eh alleine 30, äh, Bösewichte
Instant Death
Von Pfeil in die Seite
Oder wie sagt der Smash-Spieler da?
One-Hit-KO, oder?
Fabian
Äh ja, danach gucken wir nochmal, Smash ist gut, Leute
Ich hab's verstanden
Ihr wollt jetzt nochmal gucken
Also mich hat, bei Smash hat mich, ich hab leider nicht gesehen, was, hä, was die neue Fähigkeit von Hell 63 war
Wuff
Warum sagt die Wuff?
Bäh
Die Animationen sind echt krass, da hat, irgendjemand hat grad geschrieben Animationen
Aber es wirkt, wenn das so dynamisch funktioniert in-Game auch, das ist echt nice gemacht
Guck, so ist das
Gegner, Pfeil in die Seite, Instant-Tod
Ellie, in die Seite geschossen, rennt
Das hat natürlich auch keiner gesehen, wo sie hingerannt ist, aber
Hatten wir's ja gestern schon mal, Tomb Raider
Wachen in Stels spielen ist eh immer so ne Sache für sich
She came through here
Oh, nicht ins Knie, das ist gefährlich, das kennen wir aus Skyrim
Schreckt
Die Frage ist, ich mein, das macht sich immer geil, ich versteh das, und es wär ja auch alles da weitig unfair
Die Frage ist, die ich mir immer stelle, weil das sieht man nicht nur in Games, das haben sie auch immer in, in Filmen und sonst was
Ich mein, irgendjemand plant ja diese Files oder muss das programmieren
Ich mein, wo, wo ist der Sinn davon, das frag ich mich in Filmen auch immer
Das ist ja wieder so ne schöne Szene, aber ich weiß, es ist ein Game, Leute, ja, und cool, Story, Max, ist gut
Aber guck mal
Der hat, der hat quasi Ellie auf, auf der Erde, lässt sich dann kicken
Und dann bleibt er erstmal ne halbe Stunde stehen
Um seine Axt vom Rücken zu holen, wie auch immer er die da befestigt hat, um dann wieder drauf zu hauen
Warum?
Wozu?
Das wird doch keiner so machen, der noch irgendwie beiverstanden ist
Oh, Schreckt
Smorg
Ja, ja, steht ganz genau, so sieht's aus
Ich hab auch Augen
Hm, wo könnte sie hin sein?
Hm
Wo könnte sie nur sein?
Man weiß es nicht
Man hört sie auch nicht
Man sieht sie auch nicht
Sie stellst halt
Ich find nicht, dass die PS4 zu teuer ist
Sony bringt wenigstens ordentliche, ähm, Exklusivspiele raus
Aber was heißt, die Spiele sind überteuert? Konsolenspiele sind immer ein bisschen teurer als PC-Spiele
Ich find's auch, dass es insgesamt zu teuer ist, ja
Aber von allen Konsolen, wenn man halt eben nicht PC spielen will, ist die PS4 immer die beste Wahl zurzeit
Das sage ich als Xbox-Fanboy
Was mich dann aber eigentlich nicht mehr zum Xbox-Fanboy macht, ne?
Ist mein Blown
Wow
Ich fand's ja im ersten Teil cool, dass du dann mit Joel quasi die Gegner geownt hast
Das war noch irgendwie, irgendwie plausibel, ja?
Joel war ein ausgewachsener Kerl und es war auch nicht so einfach, viele Gegner auf einmal zu ownen
Aber der Ellie ist, was weiß ich, wie alt wird Ellie hier jetzt sein? Irgendwie 20 oder 90, keine Ahnung
Ähm, warum ownt Ellie auf einmal irgendwie 20 Leute?
Im ersten Teil konnte man auch sagen, okay, das sind halt dumme Zombies
Nein, das sind ja keine Zombies, das sind Pilz, Pilzbefallene
Eww
Dancegame
Ja, Bogen im Nahkampf ist auch immer sowas, was wir gerne in Spielen und Filmen machen
Wobei es absolut keinen Effekt hat, ob du einem den Bogen vor den Latz klatscht oder nicht
Oh, oh, geht weiter
Wird bestimmt gut
Wer hat jetzt zwar...
Das, das, das, das Fighten in der Form ist nicht so wahnsinnig gefallen
Es hat mich sehr Tomb Raider, sorry, Tomb Raider-mäßig erinnert
Aber, ja, also Naughty Dog hat, glaube ich, noch nie Scheiße gemacht
Die können das
Okay, jetzt müssen wir noch, was, was wollten wir noch gucken?
Death Stranding wollten wir noch gucken
Aber vorher mussten wir noch scheinbar Sony...
Äh, äh, warte mal
Was hat, was hatte denn Ubisoft noch?
Haben wir da irgendwas verpasst?
Okay, Ra...
Nee, das interessiert mich nicht
Trials Rising
Das kann ja Krieger spielen oder so, das interessiert mich auch nicht
Division 2 juckt mich auch nicht
Mario Rabbids Donkey Kong Adventure
Okay, wem das Spiel gefällt
Ähm, Sea of Thieves in gut
Ganz, äh...
Starlink
Starfox
What?
The Crew 2 juckt mich auch nicht
Assassin's Creed haben wir...
Oh, das neue For Honor Add-On
Das müssen wir uns auch angucken, da haben wir was zu lachen
Okay, mehr, mehr gab's da nicht
Das war sonst eine Ahnung
Aber jetzt gucken wir uns erst einmal Death Stranding an
Death Stranding E3
Alles klar
For, For Honor?
For Honor ist richtig Lull 4D
Dedicated Server, Lull
So, gucken wir mal
Das wird übelst verstören, das weißt du
Oh!
Viel zu laut
What the fuck?
Die Geräusche!
Uh!
Okay, das wird verstörend
Die letzten Trailer waren schon verstörend, keiner hat's verstanden
Das wird heute, das wird da bestimmt nicht anders
What's your level?
I've got the extinction factor
But I think you got me beat
You can see them, right?
No, but I can sense them
Wanna come work for me?
Must be tough out here on your own
I can't help you with that
I make deliveries
That's all
Um was geht's?
Okay, ich erwarte gar nicht, dass man versteht, um was es da geht
Weil das ist einfach...
Der Typ ist komplett... voll expanded brain
Mehr geht da nicht
Kojima!
Kojima ist... ist das next level brain
Das versteht man nicht
Ja, ja
Ich hab' schon recht, Tribolon
Lootbox!
Warum macht das eine Lootbox die einfach auf?
Ja, das ist der Typ von The Walking Dead
Ach, der braucht noch einen Key!
Ja, verstehe
Kann er sich doch einen kaufen
Noch mehr Lootboxen
No
Ich hab' keinen Schirm, um was es geht
Er sieht gut aus
Soviel ist sicher
Headed into town
Watch yourself
Those things never stay gone for long
The timefall fast forwards whatever it touches
But it can't wash everything away
The past just won't let go
I'll see you around
Some poor bridges
Warum hat die Dornen an ihrem Anzug?
Sam, was ist dein Status?
Die Densität des Kyrilliums erhöht sich
Mein Status ist verdammt
Sag mal, was machen die mit dem Sound?
Der Sound ist mal übelst leise und dann wieder übelst laut
Kannst du aus dem Regen aussteigen?
Nein
Sie schließen meine Position
Ich muss mich bewegen, bevor sie wissen, dass ich hier bin
Sam, wenn einer dieser Dinge dich isst, wird es einen Boyd auslösen
Du kommst sicher zurück, aber die Umgebung wird immer größer
Ich hab' eine Idee
Big Brain
Easy Clap
Was zum Teufel gucken wir uns da gerade an?
What?
Eine Kryptowährung für einen Tag hält den Zeitfall weg
Hier ist noch mal Eating Sounds
Du bist zu spät
Du weißt immer noch nicht, wer ich bin, oder?
Ach, die war das!
Ich wusste nur, dass ich ihn mal irgendwo gesehen hab'
Das war hier der...
Das war...
Das war Dings da
Er mit dem Baby
Ihn hab' ich jetzt nicht erkannt
Und Lindsey Swagger...
Ach nee, Wagner kenn' ich nicht
Okay
Ich weiß immer noch nicht, um was es in dem Game geht
Oh, ist noch nicht fertig
Na, das ist wahrscheinlich Lindsey, sonst was hab' ich noch nie gehört
Okay, ähm...
Was haben wir sonst noch?
Gab's noch irgendwas...
Hm...
Gab's noch was?
Irgendwas, was wir uns angucken müssen?
Wenn's nix mehr gibt, gucken wir uns noch mal Smash an
Guck noch Spider-Man
Sieht auch nice aus
Bin ja kein Fan von Comic...
Spielen
So wirklich, ne?
Können wir aber machen
Ghost of...
soll ich sagen oder wollt ihr sagen meine emotion
so einen so einen trailer macht man wenn man nichts zu zeigen hat
oder es leckt p2p server im hintergrund
das ist ja nicht weit von der realität weg oder
anguckt das ist die echte gaming experience
select switcher
noch ein weg wird habe ich das jetzt richtig verstanden hat der hatte die
jetzt geohnt okay da hat die geohnt nachdem sie durch die festung gelaufen
ist ich meine sieht gar nicht so übel aus
leider ist das game halt naja es schon ein bisschen abgekackt am anfang okay
das werden aber geguckt klaus zu schieber haben wir noch zwei
jahre okay wir fangen wir mit zwei der mann
an
habe ich die wenigsten jetzt hat man auch wenn die battle royale wird es
nicht weil es aber die luft raus vor allem gibt es auch schon okay da habe
ich jetzt ist überhaupt nicht meins comic comic games und so komme ich
verfilmung spiele überlegt doch schon mal falls noch was
gibt was wir angucken müssen da kommt man das nämlich gleich noch
danach also noch ein bisschen was zu tun haben
ach moment das gameplay dem katzbau man
nicht mehr wollen trailer und der trailer geht so guckt mal leute hier jetzt hier
sieht man das problem was aktuell so ist und das problem auch bei allen
möglichen pressekonferenz uns was guckt man der trailer ist 8 also wenn das so
stimmt der trainer ist neun minuten dass die gameplay demo ist sieben suchende
creations iSCs by morgan expenditure a frage孩子 sleever biogên GAZ
reue nur zur presskonferenz und genau davon 이게 mangeldrück advisory iSCs wie alles anderen dinstrioe ist nicht möglich dasい
Demo ist sieben Minuten.
Fällt euch auf, dass das irgendwie
ein bisschen... Achso, das ist
E3 2017.
Okay, ich nehm's wieder zurück.
Egal, aber das stimmt trotzdem.
Stimmt trotzdem, was ich gesagt hab.
Äh,
nein, die HTTP-Listener-Class von
uns jetzt nicht angucken. Aber es stimmt trotzdem,
was ich gesagt hab. Unabhängig davon, dass es in dem
Beispiel jetzt Schwachsinn war.
Das gab was, ja. Aber es ist halt
so. Kannst du ohne
Probleme auf andere Sachen übertragen.
Erstmal Trailer, Trailer, Trailer. Kommt irgendein Gameplay.
Nichts an das Gameplay. Äh, Video
hinten dran. Okay, äh.
Okay, der Trailer
ist... Guck mal, das ist auch
sieben Minuten. Ne, Gameplay-Trailer.
Hat das kein Trailer gehabt, das Game?
Ich glaub, das hat kein Gameplay.
Das hat kein Trailer.
Da müssen wir uns das jetzt angucken.
For the players.
Nicht?
Sagen sie doch. Warum haben sie
das jetzt eigentlich noch nicht gesagt? Das sagen
die doch immer. Bei jeder
bei jeder Sache
zelebriert doch, zelebrieren sie doch
immer. For the player.
Players.
Comic-Verfilmung.
Juckt mich überhaupt nicht.
Okay, wann geht das Gameplay los?
Come to the party.
Just in time for the fireworks.
Generic Bösewicht.
Why is he letting everyone out?
I'll head...
Everyone just quietly go back into your cells
and lock the door behind you. Okay?
Please?
Äh, okay, er klopft.
Drum.
Irgendwie erinnert mich das, dass, dass,
das Kloppsystem ein bisschen an die,
in den Batman-Games,
was bei diesen
in seinem Grund,
in den совремlichen Zeit.
So wie ich,
Moment, das war das in der Art,
dass Simon oder auch so in dem ersten Batman-Game,
mit diesen.
Wie.
Dä, da ist ein Verfängnis rein,
so rum,
und.
Da habe ich in der Mitte der Klammer hassen,
und das war Business auch.
Ich finde Comic-Games
finde ich so Resident-Sleeper.
Cyberpunk-Trader
fand ich...
Naja.
Ich bin gespannt, was rauskommt.
Also, ich fand es geil, dass man mal was gesehen hat.
Aber es war halt nicht so viel...
Das hat nichts gesagt. Großartig.
Boah, ist das langweilig.
Destiny 2 Forsaken.
Okay, es gibt einen neuen.
Es gibt einen neuen Destiny-DLC, oder was?
Nein, ich meine, mit Comic-Games
meine ich Games, die auf Comics basieren.
Gegen Cel-Shading-Grafik
habe ich überhaupt nichts.
Fire Emblem.
Da hat man nicht viel gesehen von.
Außer, dass man irgendwie
Gert Hilde oder wie sie hieß, spielt.
Wie hieß die?
Wie hieß die von Fire Emblem?
Gertrude, Gert Hilde.
Edelgard.
Edelgard, genau.
Oh, das ist so Resident Sleeper.
Das ist so Resident Sleeper.
Nein, das ist nicht Nutz.
Das ist Sleep.
Nein, nein, nein, Leute.
Ihr wolltet das sehen, jetzt müssen wir das auch gucken.
Man kann nicht erst sagen, das will man gucken
und dann zwischendrin sagen, das will man nicht mal gucken.
Danach gucken wir noch Ghost of Tsushima.
Warum fängt man Wörter mit T-S-U an?
Das kann doch keiner aussprechen.
Wobei, das sind die Japaner.
Die Japaner sprechen das ja eh immer alles so
so betont und zackig aus.
Die Japaner sagen nicht Tsushima,
dann sagt man Tsushima oder irgendwie sowas.
Tsushima.
Die Japaner sind ja immer übelst so zackig.
Und betont beim Aussprechen.
Juggernaut.
Warum ist der inverted?
Ja, das halte ich auch nicht.
Da darf ich jetzt nichts zum Thema Realismus sagen.
Das ist ein Comic-Superhelden-Game.
Oh mein Gott!
Meine Immersion.
Okay, GLHF.
Next.
With Flute.
Es wird geblasen.
Ja dann.
Lassen wir nochmal blasen.
Okay, Destiny Forsaken.
Gucken wir auch noch.
Das ist ja grausam.
Vor allem der...
Wow.
Oh.
Jetzt kommt die ganze Finesse.
Gleich macht er mit 360 sonst was.
360 Flute oder...
360 Claymore Flöte around the house.
Sonst was.
Mit Dubstep.
Das ist komplett mind blowing hier.
Huge place.
Massive.
Massive place.
Conquer your very soul.
Don't leave it.
There's a chance.
Die Flöte soll ausgehen.
Das ist wie der...
Oh, oh.
Oh.
Nghh.
Gi.
Mhhh.
Oh, oh.
Es geht ab.
Hahaha.
Yeah.
Nice one.
Hahaha.
Heh.
Nochmal.
Hah?
Leute.
Nochmal.
Was ist das für ein Sound?
Regen, der übersteuert.
Die Flöte.
Ja, den hört der mal auf.
Der Regen.
Er hört, er hört, er hört.
Okay.
Spann.
Der Regen, der übersteuert.
Der Regen übersteuert.
Hahaha.
Der Regen, den hört der mal auf.
Der Regen ist ungleichmäßig laut.
Ich meine, was ist mit dem Sound kaputt?
Das ist übelst kaputt.
Ist das der Nuzzle Sound Guy oder sowas?
Wobei, das sind alte StarCraft-Memes.
Das versteht keiner.
Kennt noch jemand den Nuzzle Sound Guy?
Beziehungsweise der NASL Sound Guy.
Moin, Patrick.
Da läuft einer mit dem Hut und einem Schwert rum.
Der kann dich auch nicht sagen.
Und es wird geflötet.
Also es ist harte Blasarbeit gerade.
Mr. For Army, das kann ich mir richtig vorstellen.
Dass demnächst irgendwie einer...
Den Epic Sucks Guy, den kennt ihr ja noch.
Dass dann irgendwie einer demnächst den Epic Flut Guy erstellt.
10-Stunden-Version.
10 Stunden.
Sony Press Conference, Epic Flut Guy.
Flut.
Epona sieht doch da mal komisch aus.
Der war schlecht, ich weiß.
4D-Sound.
Ja, das ist komplett kaputt, der Sound.
Das ist Witcher 3 Asiari-Skin.
Oh, jetzt kommt gleich krasses Samurai.
Samurai-Action.
Weil wir ja wissen, ist ja allgemein bekannt,
dass Samurais mit dem Schwert auch Panzer durchschneiden können.
Schreckt.
Ich glaube, das Game sieht nicht ganz gut aus.
Die Grafik ist nur ein bisschen verwaschen hier.
Beziehungsweise das Encoding vom Stream.
Ey, never.
Never.
Leute, das ist ein Game, was wieder...
Ich weiß, ich habe mich vorher schon mal über den Scheiß ausgelassen.
Aber das ist wieder ein Game, das einen auch historisch macht.
So.
Warum?
Kann man mal erklären?
Läuft der Typ mit einem Schild und einem Speer
in den Gegner rein.
In das Schwert vom Gegner.
Warum?
Beziehungsweise der Typ da hinten.
Guckt es euch mal an.
Der Typ.
So.
Normalerweise würde er da stehen bleiben.
Aber nee.
Ey, George, du willst rein?
Warum?
Könnt ihr das nicht mal versuchen,
so den Hauch von irgendwie sinnvollen Sachen in solchen Games zu machen?
Weil es ein alter Stecher ist.
Das wird sein, genau.
Oh, Krill.
Nee, altes Krill.
You're late.
You're impatient.
Where's the monk?
The bastards beat me to him.
Now they're torturing him at the temple.
Shrek.
Come on.
You think the monk's a hero.
We need him, Massacre.
We can take them.
No.
Remember Sako Bridge.
They strike quietly.
They kill the monk.
It's a hard nugget, Sam.
Fuck him.
No.
Come on.
You're staying by Krill's Déjà-vu.
You're standing by Krill's Déjà-vu.
Come on.
Right, Krill, this is the only language I have in it.
Look, this is the only language I can speak in.
Alright, says that person.
You've been kendi.
Alright.
Nothing is
This informations has, uh, no problem with ridiculously small
value Algeria-ooo.
Just get there, you on your own.
In Amaranla, who's his man?
Niba, who loves you?
Nani?
20 Rock, dos Sushi-Mug.
I had a stuffed Aflopan.
Please, I do not want this family.
Will that way?
Chama got unha me.
Us mi che yaven sagt.
Ci obe lat no.
Ci ne varia.
Das wird erstmal gelootet.
Also, Herr Samurai, ich muss schon sehr bitten.
Guck mal.
Der hat noch eindeutig Loot.
Der hatte nen Horn und nen Schwert.
Die hatten alle.
Du kannst nicht einfach gehen jetzt.
Guck mal.
Alles noch.
Guck mal hier.
Und ich mein, zumindest mal irgendwie Rüstung oder sowas.
Ne, ne.
He called reinforcements.
We have to move.
Masako.
Stand aside, Jin.
You betrayed my family.
Run.
If we fight,
Mongols win.
They already won.
Der winnt?
Jetzt kommt Hanzo old-clay.
Ryo wa weke tiki wo koro.
Oder so ähnlich.
Forgive me.
Ich mein, ich find, also optisch hier der Fight, naja, keine Ahnung, aber hinten sieht das jetzt wirklich nice aus.
Oh, bloody screen.
You know, that's our enemy.
Slow mo.
Rekt, würd ich sagen.
Das ist noch sowas.
Das muss ich jetzt loswerden.
Das machen sie nämlich auch immer.
In Film und Spielen und sowas.
Keiner.
Und wir können jetzt im Mittelalter leider keinen fragen, ja?
Aber fragt mal irgendeinen, der irgendwie Klingen schärft.
Was passiert mit Klingen, wenn sie in die Erde gesteckt werden?
Sie werden stumpf.
Deswegen wird niemand, der sich auf sein Schwert verlassen muss, weil sein Leben davon abhängt, sich jemals in die Erde stecken.
Das macht man nicht.
Cool story, Max.
Schlitz.
Ist ja eine Seinswachs.
Ja, das macht's aber auch nicht besser.
So, okay, was sollten wir noch gucken?
Transference.
Das Game ist bei mir schon mal fast durchgefallen, weil ich den Namen nicht aussprechen kann.
So.
Okay, das geht nur zwei Minuten.
Das können wir kurz reinwerfen.
Ach, ist das das mit Frodo auf der Bühne?
Genau.
Okay, gut. Warten wir mal kurz an.
To the digital space.
We're completely safe.
Hello, everyone. My name is Elijah Wood, co-founder of Spectrovision.
Though we're known for our film content, we're also avid gamers.
And the opportunity to partner with Ubisoft was something we had to be a part of.
And my name is Benoit Che, game director on Transference.
Together, we combine the storytelling techniques of film with interactivity.
Interactivity of video games.
Enabling us to create this unique, deeply immersive world with a dark and unselling narrative.
Have you ever dreamed of entering someone else's consciousness?
Exploring their darkest thoughts and most intimate secrets?
Ich würde gar nicht wissen, was die meisten Leute so im Kopf haben.
Wirklich nicht.
No.
With Transference, we're bringing a first-person exploration game into a chilling new dimension.
To escape, you must go hands-on to search for clues.
Solve puzzles while shifting between the perspectives of each family member.
And attempt to piece together their mystery.
This fall, in VR and on traditional platforms,
we welcome you to uncover the secrets hiding in this mind-bending psychological thriller
that will leave you with haunting memories long after you put down the controller.
This is Transference.
What's going on?
Where's Mom?
Is' das ein Game mit Schauspielern drinne?
Das ist weiß. Solche Games sind meistens übelst cringe.
Is' das Jack Black? Nee, oder?
Nee.
Nee, ist es nicht.
Are you comfortable?
I know this rig's a bit cumbersome, but that's always the way with these new prototypes, huh?
And all you have to do is just...
just be.
Ich war keine Spiel mit echten Schauspielern.
Ich war keine Spiel mit echten Schauspielern, hör mal.
Ich war kein Spiel mit echten Schauspielern, hör mal.
Lousy FATHER und mein Able.
Lousy HUSBAND 2.
If you're gonna sleep.
You've seen how rotten that's gotten, huh?
But all that's gonna change.
We're all gonna be together.
All of our hard work.
All of our sacrifices.
That's my gift to you.
Us.
Help me! Help me! We!
Dad? Warum tust du das?
Ich liebe dich, mein Sohn. Ich liebe dich mit all meinem Herzen.
Ich liebe dich mit all meinem Herzen.
In den Assassin's Creed Trailer, den haben wir schon geschaut, ja.
Sogar in den gameplay trailer
Ist das Johnny Cash, oder was ist das?
Guck mal, das ist Vala.
Sieht voll so aus
Bloß halt mit Pistole
Okay, ich hab keine Ahnung, was mir das sagen sollte.
Aber ich hab Destiny 2 auch nicht gespielt.
Aber war es ist nicht
So, was anderes?
Da hat man noch, äh, Schellendostatus.
Das sagt mir auch gar nichts, ey.
Es kommt doch wohl einiges Neues.
Wo haben sie denn das gestern gezeigt?
Bei wem haben sie denn das gestern gezeigt?
Moment, doch, doch, das kennen wir.
Das kennen wir.
Das haben wir gesehen, genau, das war bei Microsoft.
Das kennen wir schon.
Das ist das, worauf wir uns alle gefragt haben, was soll das eigentlich sein?
Ja, ja, das kennen wir schon.
Ja, das kennen wir schon.
Ah, es geht zwei Minuten, das können wir nochmal anlassen.
Samurai sind dieses Jahr schwer im Trend.
Schon wieder ein Juggernaut-Gegner.
Deine Tod wird nicht so schnell kommen.
Okay, eins haben wir noch, einen Vorschlag haben wir noch, und zwar das neue Game von Remedy.
Das hätten wir doch eigentlich auch bei Microsoft sehen müssen.
Habe ich das schon wieder vergessen?
Ach ne, das war Sony.
Ist das von Remedy überhaupt?
Hat gerade jemand im Chat geschrieben.
Tatsächlich.
Okay, gucken wir mal.
Remedy macht gute Games.
Makes pain best.
Ambient sounds, gut zu wissen.
Und Rituals, you can keep travelling deeper.
The fuck?
Das hat, das hat bisschen was von Quantum Break.
Oder?
Das hat schon bisschen was von Quantum Break.
Weil ich die Untertitel ausgemacht habe, ehrlich gesagt.
Okay, ich weiß nicht, um was es geht, und was da überhaupt gerade passiert, aber auf Remedy kann man sich in der Regel verlassen.
Remedy macht in der Regel immer super Games.
Gar nicht mal so sehr.
Ich würde gar nicht mal so sehr sagen, weil die vom Gameplay so ultra krass nie dagewesen sind, sondern die Remedy Games machen es echt mit der Story.
Sowohl die ersten beiden Max Payne Spiele, Alan Wake, Quantum Break, das war alles jetzt nichts, würde ich sagen, wo du sagen würdest, oh nee, das hat es aber Gameplay-technisch noch nie gegeben oder so.
Aber die Story war immer gut.
Und die haben mit Sam Lake einfach einen super Drehbuchschreiber.
Nennt man das Drehbuch bei einem Spiel?
Scriptschreiber.
Sam Lake best.
So, das war es.
Ich würde sagen, wir sind durch, wenn keine weiteren...
Ja, Max Payne war von Remedy.
Remedy hat... so viele Spiele haben die ja nicht.
Die haben ja nicht so viele, ne?
Die haben in den letzten 12 Jahren nicht allzu viele Spiele rausgebracht.
Dafür waren alle Spiele, gut, außer die, die ich nicht kenne, war iOS Game, lol.
Alle der Hauptgames von denen waren richtig geil.
Gutes Alan Wake, Adonis, keine Ahnung, das habe ich noch nicht gespielt.
Das waren alle richtig geil.
Max Payne 1 ist eines meiner absoluten Lieblingsspiele.
Leider ist es grafisch halt schon sehr angestorben.
Max Payne 2 war auch übelst geil.
Alan Wake eigentlich fast noch besser.
Wobei man das mit Adon spielen muss, weil das einfach die Story sonst mittendrin aufhört.
Das war auch mega Fail.
Ähm...
Quantum Break war auch gut.
Die haben nur geile Games gemacht.
Und die waren alle gameplaymäßig nicht gut.
Also, nee, Schwachsinn.
Nicht herausragend so, ne?
Also, gut waren die schon.
Aber nicht so, dass du sagen musst, boah, krass, mega toll, neues.
Die Story war einfach geil.
Ja, okay.
Der Mr. Milchmann.
Quick Maths.
12, eindeutig.
Wollt ihr mir sagen, das ist nicht 12?
Also, passt mal auf.
Ich zeige euch das jetzt mal.
Wir rechnen das jetzt mal aus, okay?
Wie viel das ist.
Mein Rechner rechnet das jetzt.
Also.
2018 minus 1996.
The fuck?
2018 minus 1996 gleich 12.
Bam.
So.
Da steht's.
Das muss stimmen.
Wissenschaftlich belegt.
So, gut.
Fertig.
Sind wir durch.
Ich muss sagen, heute war der Tag, wo ich am meisten Spaß mit den Trailern hatte.
Wahrscheinlich, weil wir alles querbeet geguckt haben.
Die einzige Sprache, wo 2018 minus 1996 12 sein könnte, ist wahrscheinlich JavaScript.
In JavaScript kann alles bei allem rauskommen.
Das weiß man nicht so genau.
Gut.
Ich mach Schluss.
Wir sehen uns die Tage wieder.
Ich muss nämlich noch ein bisschen streben sollen, dass ich wieder electable bin für
Partner.
Mr.
Milchmann.
Genau.
In JavaScript.
In JavaScript ist 2018 minus 1996 falsch.
Ja, das passt zu JavaScript.
Nee, nee, nee, nee.
Noch besser.
In JavaScript ist es not a number.
2018 minus 1996.
None ist das.
Okay, Leute.
Macht's gut.
Wir sehen uns die Tage.
Bis dann.
See you.
Ciao.